let's bring in dr ashish jha he's the
dean of brown university school of
public health
dr jean it's good to see you on this
holiday monday thank you so much
for working this morning we certainly
appreciate it let's talk about this
the biden administration had set the
goal of 70 for one dose for all
americans they made it to 67.
now people look at that and say oh they
didn't make the goal but there's
something
to celebrate here is there not yeah good
morning gail thanks for having me back
absolutely i mean i always thought that
was the most ambitious goal
of the goals that the president has said
on vaccinations and two-thirds of adult
americans have gotten a shot
that's fabulous and it's made an
enormous difference and i think we
should absolutely be celebrating
but what can we do to convince the
others i don't know i know you must feel
like a broken record i think
it's good to point out to people that
the people who are getting sick from
covet
are the people who are not vaccinated
isn't that true
it is absolutely true we still have
hundreds of americans dying every week
of this disease
99 plus percent of them are people who
are unvaccinated
uh that's where this virus really is
circulating among unvaccinated americans
and if you don't want to be one of those
people
it's really straightforward go get
vaccinated as i and all my family have
yeah all of us here too at this table
what do you say about the fourth of july
celebrations listen
people were partying they were gathering
they were really celebrating as
as nancy just said in full force we've
still got that delta variant that's
circulating around
how worried should people be about this
yeah i think if you're having gatherings
with vaccinated people i don't think you
need to be worried i think we're
for that i mean i had a july 4th
barbecue with about 20-25 friends
it was outside it was great and i didn't
feel like it was risky at all even the
white house event
if all the adults were vaccinated i
think it's a pretty safe thing
what i worry about is when you have
large groups of unvaccinated people
getting together and dr john you know
that there are people in the group that
are unvaccinated
that's what that's what freaks me out a
little bit you know they're unvaccinated
well you have kids who are under 12 who
are of course unvaccinated but
if people around them are all vaccinated
i think it's pretty safe
but if you have a large gathering with
adults who are unvaccinated i would
worry about those gatherings how
effective are the vaccines against the
delta virus
against the delta variant you know i'll
tell you gail this has continued to be a
pleasant surprise to me these vaccines
are incredibly effective against all the
variants out there including the delta
variant
about 90 percent booster shots do you
know anything about that's what we want
to know
booster shots are we going to have to
take a booster shot in the fall
not in the fall i just don't see it i
look we don't know
i doubt we're going to need boosters
anytime soon maybe next year
kind of the way we do the annual flu
shot maybe but i'm not at all convinced
of that yet either
we'll have to see what the data says all
right dr ashish jaw thank you so much
for your time
good to see you thank you